hey guys it's me in this video we want
to share the secrets of how to lose that
last ten pounds okay now what's
interesting it's very unnatural to lose
weight in general the body doesn't like
losing weight it goes against its own
purpose of trying to survive so anything
that is losing is something that's very
unnatural but there are things that you
can do strategically to really dig deep
into losing the last resistant stubborn
weight okay so number one zero sugars
now you as you may already know that
anything high in the glycemic index
anything high in sugar increases insulin
and insulin blocks fat burning you will
not be able to lose weight in the
presence of insulin and that includes
all the hidden sugars like the breads
the pasta the cereal the crackers the
biscuits the waffles pancakes muffins
juice alcohol and fruit okay we need to
actually bring all those out of the diet
because we don't want any excess insulin
okay alright number two intense exercise
the intensity of exercise is what can
trigger the most powerful fat burning
hormone called growth hormone and here's
the catch-22 with intense exercise
exercise that will help you lose weight
if you recover from it all the benefit
of exercise occurs in the recovery so
yes we need to do a full-body
high-intensity workout but that will
only work if you don't overtrain it only
works if you recover from that workout
okay in the sleep so if you're working
out and you're sore the next day or
you're tired the next day then give it
some more time but the combination of
high intensity full-body compound
resistant exercise with recovery will
increase some massive growth hormone
changes which then will burn fat okay
number three eight plus hours of sleep
now why because most the fat burning and
most the benefit of exercise occurs when
you're sleeping if you're only getting
six hours or even seven hours of sleep
that can greatly reduce your chances of
losing weight and the key is has to be
quality it has to be long enough
and it's totally okay if you take a nap
during the day but we need that eight
plus hours of sleep every night
number four two meals per day now here's
the thing we don't want you to be hungry
we don't want you to cut calories that
doesn't work
it creates starvation but there's a
thing called intermittent fasting that
will greatly improve your fat burning'
specifically growth hormone is triggered
by intermittent fasting and what that
means is that we're eating a couple
meals not three meals a day and we're
going to add fat at the meal to be able
to go longer so it's not about reducing
the calories from fat it's about going
longer because what happens when you
have more than two meals a day every
time you eat you trigger insulin so
we're trying to keep insolent very very
low and two meals a day is a perfect
combination now when should you have
those two meals a day number one if
you're not hungry in the morning do not
eat breakfast wait till lunch okay if
you're hungry in the morning have that
breakfast but then go all the way until
5:00 6:00 and have dinner okay and that
would be the perfect combination or the
frequency of eating number five no
snacking between meals why because every
time you eat no matter what you eat you
trigger insulin and insulin blocks fat
burning so we don't want to snack if you
want to actually have like some nuts or
some cheese have it at the meal not in
between the meal because if you keep
spiking insulin you're never going to be
able to lose weight a lot of people have
this thing called insulin resistance
which is basically like a pre-diabetic
situation which keeps the insulin four
to five times higher than an average
person so no snacking and two meals a
day will actually correct incentive
resistance okay and you'll go longer and
longer and you add more fat of your if
you're hungry so you can go longer
without eating but we don't want to
snack even if it's something healthy all
right so that's actually number five
number six protein three to six ounces
per meal now why because if you have too
much protein you can increase insulin
anything more than 35 grams spikes
insulin so we want smaller amounts of
protein we can have them twice a day but
we don't want to have a large amounts of
protein okay that's another tip number
seven seven to ten cups of vegetables
now this is interesting because unless
you do those vegetables you won't get
the minerals specifically potassium you
need about 4700 milligrams of potassium
every single day and that that's the
quantity of vegetables that you're
supposed to consume to get that
potassium you're not going to get it
without the potassium you can't curb
cravings you can't metabolize protein as
well you can't build your stomach acids
it's the most important mineral that you
need especially for losing weight and
many people don't have the quantity now
we just want to make sure you can have
two big salads you can blend it but
here's the key if you're consuming a
type of vegetable that you're not used
to like even kale or any of the
cruciferous vegetables and you start
bloating or you get constipated change
up the vegetable because we can't have
you bloated a lot of the microbes in
your gut eat fiber and if you overwhelm
the veg of the microbes with too much
fiber at one time they're not used to it
and you're constipated you're bloated
you're not going to lose weight okay so
make sure you're eating vegetables that
you can digest and that you don't have
any type of digestive problem okay so
those are the seven secrets to lose that
ten last ten pounds and this will work
if you follow them a lot of times people
will focus on one more than the other
but whatever you're missing plug it in
and write your success stories below hey
thanks for watching I want to send you a
gift in exchange for a little survey the
survey is very short and I just want
your opinion on a question so click the
link below fill the survey and check
your inbox